في المنزل هذا الذي بدا غالبيه جدرانه
مدمره اضطرت اسره الى اتخذه مسكن ومؤول
لها بعد انفرت ميزاحم الميليشيات الحوثيه
فالسكن فيه مؤقت رغم انه اكثر خطرا على
حياتهم من ذاك الخطر الذي تهددهم لاعوا
منه في المنازل قبل النزول
الى هنا للمطار القديم
واضطرينا نحن نسكن داخل
انا واسرتي وعائلتي
وانو اعاني من السؤال ما يشاء ومن القصف
ومن الحرب هذه
كل يوم قذائف مع الحرب هذا وضرب وهنا
للحاره والمواطنين وترحيب الاطفال
والمواطنين
غربيه
المعيشه في ظل الحرب
ظروفنا الخاصه
من هنا
والمستقبلين ما هو من الله بس الان يعني
اناشيد المنظمات واصحاب الخير بالايتام
الان ما فيش حد مني الفتهم ولا احد ولا هم
ولا من يجيب لهم ولا اي حاجه
اكثر من 3000
يعيشون الوضع نفسه مع التردد الوضع
المعيشي خاصه اولئك الذين يعيشون في
المخيمات فالغالبيه منهم لا يحصلون على
احتياجاتهم الاساسيه من الغذاء والملابس
الشتويه التي تقيهم اقل ما يمكن من البرد
سعيد العربي العربيه تعز